Some big
news announced from
the Biden administration today.
The Taliban has killed an ISIS leader.
According to Biden administration
officials, that leader
is the same person who planned
the deadly attack on American troops
and Afghan civilians at the Kabul airport
during the chaotic U.S.
withdrawal from the country.
13 American servicemen
as you'll remember,
and more than 170 Afghans were killed
in that bombing back in 20, 21.
Joining me now
from the White House is John Kirby,
the coordinator
for strategic communications
for the National Security Council.
John, thank you for coming for coming on.
What more can you tell us about this?
What was this ISIS leader's name?
How was he killed?
Well, we're not at liberty to talk
about his specific name
necessarily, Kate, but we are confident,
based on information
that we've been able to glean
that this is the individual
who was, as we've called him,
the mastermind
of that Abigail Gate attack.
And, of course, our condolences.
Our thoughts
and prayers continue to go out
to all the families
of those 13 servicemembers lost,
as well as
the family members
of the Afghan victims
of that terrible, terrible day.
But we know that the Taliban took
this individual out,
killed him in an operation
that they were conducting on their own
without any assistance,
certainly from the United States.
And it's important,
I think, for viewers to remember
that the Taliban and ISIS
are mortal enemies there in Afghanistan.
They continue to fight one another,
as a matter of fact.
Now, this is the third senior leader
that the Taliban have killed in terms of
ISI's key leadership.
John, can you talk to me
about the hesitancy to talk in
releasing the leader's name?
I was just looking this morning
and saw
back in the beginning of April, CENTCOM
when a press release
very clearly named
another another ISIS leader that was
taken out in Syria.
Yeah, I wish I could give you
more context to your Kate
We're just not able to speak publicly
about the name right now.
There's there's reasons for that.
But I can tell you
that we're confident
that this is the individual
who in fact, masterminded that attack.
John, after the Abigail attack,
everyone will remember
President Biden's speech that night
and he vowed retribution.
I mean, he said,
we will not forgive, we will not forget.
We will hunt you down and make you pay.
The fact
that the Taliban is
who killed this leader does
does this speak to the limits of U.S.
capabilities in Afghanistan
after the withdrawal?
No, actually,
I think it validates
the president's decision
to leave Afghanistan altogether.
You don't need to have a big presence
on the ground, boots on the ground
to go after terrorist threats,
whether they're in Afghanistan
or elsewhere,
and look
the Taliban killed this individual.
I think it's a good thing that he's gone.
I think it's a great thing
that he's no longer walking the earth
and no longer can plan attacks
and conduct attacks
against anyone let alone
American interests.
But, look,
I think it's also important to remember
we killed al-Zawahiri
while he was sitting on a balcony
in Kabul, Afghanistan,
using over the horizon capabilities.
And we've taken out other ISIS
leaders in Somalia
and in Syria, again,
using over the horizon.
What the president said at
also that day
was that we're going to make sure
we can continue to sharpen
and improve our abilities
to go
after these guys in an over
the horizon, low footprint way.
And we've actually proven that case time
and time again with this
Does does
it does
President Biden, despite administration,
trust the Taliban
any more today than they did
previous to this?
No, ma'am.
This is not this is not about trust.
Not at all.
And we didn't
we weren't involved in this.
We didn't partner with them on this.
They have said
they said in their agreement
which they signed under the Trump
administration, that they were going
to not allow Afghanistan to become a safe
haven for al Qaeda or terrorist networks.
We're going to hold them
to that commitment.
We want to see them meet that commitment.
But this is not about trust, not now.
Not the way that the Taliban
is treating its own people,
women and girls.
I mean,
they are not meeting
all their commitments
to the international community.
And we we're going to continue
to urge them to do that.
Oren Liebermann
has been following the reaction and joins
us now from the Pentagon.
So are in the mastermind
behind the Kabul attack
that left these 13 U.S.
servicemen dead.
These 170 Afghans killed.
He's now dead, killed by the Taliban.
How is the Pentagon reacting?
What are they saying?
Well, it's interesting.
We got a statement fairly late last night
from the Defense Department,
which says that the United States
had no role in this operation
or whatever happened there
that led to the death
of the senior ISI's leader.
So that's telling in and of itself
that there was no coordination
or cooperation with the Taliban,
at least according
to the Defense Department.
In what
led to the death of this ISIS leader.
Although the White House
didn't say when this had happened.
DOD saying this happened
sometime in early April.
What's unclear
is how exactly the Taliban killed
this senior ISIS leader,
whether it was a targeted attack
they were going after this leader
or whether it was simply infighting
between Isaac and the Taliban.
Last month, it was General Eric Carillo,
the commander of U.S.
Central Command, who said the ISI's K
has been carrying out more attacks
throughout the region
in which they are active.
That is Afghanistan.
And some of the surrounding countries,
but also that their goal
was to attack U.S.
interests outside of Afghanistan.
Although ultimately,
he says
they'd like to carry out
an attack on the U.S. homeland.
They are far from being able to do so
and would more likely try to target U.S.
interests abroad.
Broadly speaking,
that seeks to isolate Kaye's intent.
But the White House
saying this is one of several senior
ISIS leaders who has been killed
since the beginning of the year.
Even those who were critical of the U.S.
withdrawal from Afghanistan
have praised the death
of this senior ISIS leader.
For example, Representative
Michael McCaul,
the Republican head of the House
Foreign Relations Committee,
says this is one terrorist dead
and that itself is a good thing.
But it doesn't absolve
the Biden administration
from the responsibility
of how the withdrawal from Afghanistan
was handled and the deaths of the 13 U.S.
service members and more than 170 Afghans
in that suicide bombing
in the closing days of the withdrawal.
In fact, CNN
also spoke
with a father
of one of the Marines who was killed
in that attack,
who had largely the same sentiment.
It's good that
that the world
got rid of a terrorist in this case.
But again,
what he wants to see
is more more accountability,
more responsibility taken from
not only the White House,
but also the Pentagon.
And the State Department. Linda?
Yeah,
and of course, Ana, to talk to us
more about that,
given the fact that the U.S.
is now out of Afghanistan,
how difficult it
how challenging it is
to gather intelligence for the U.S.
and its allies on ISIS,
on other terrorism related groups?
Right now, given
they don't really have a presence there?
It's much more
difficult because it has to be done
essentially from above.
Spy satellites and drones flown, flown
in from far away.
And what the Biden administration
has called
its over the horizon capability.
They point to
a very small number of actions
that the U.S. has taken.
The the
the targeted
killing, the assassination of Zawahiri
in Kabul several months ago.
But there isn't much more to look at
in terms of
kinetic activity
that the Biden administration
has as carried out
since the withdrawal from Afghanistan.
And General Chiarelli,
again, the commander of U.S.
Central Command, has pointed out
it is much harder to gather intel
to act on that intel
now that the U.S. is out.
So that remains
one of the ongoing challenges
for the military and more broadly
for the U.S..
Oren Liebermann for us at the Pentagon,
good to have you with us. Thanks so much.